right looks like it's creating down out
there so I think we'll just start
because we have a lot of material to go
through welcome uh this talk is called
Siri makes beautiful programs
I'm very happy with the title uh
uh quite happy with the talk as well
it is uh
I mean Kate already brought it up in uh
in um
Keynote
and it's it's
um it started out as a reflection of
what I've been doing for the past few
months
and The Inspirations and literally
sources that that led to it that I
wanted both to highlight and also some
of the
wine insights that kind of came out of
it as to how we developed software and
how we're sometimes doing it wrong
the topic is going to be on mcdc which
is a terrible name uh it's an
abbreviation for modified condition
decision coverage and quickly I'd like
to do a poll like what industries people
are from is anyone in in uh like Aero
clients
fish okay good
um Automotive
no
um Rockets things that blow up
yeah okay good
uh other I don't know Vision I guess
anymore interesting Industries
some defense okay good so
um it's kind of good because that means
you've probably not been very exposed to
this
and I would start really opening like
that mcdc or courage in general or
condition coverage in general
is probably one of the most overvalued
and still underused
testing criteria that we have
um so we're gonna very quick one on that
if you want a more sort of Hands-On
tutorial and introduction to that I
recommend coming to my other talk in a
few hours where we'll be a little bit
more
um on the action
I'm going to do a thorough description
of an algorithm I designed in order to
implement support for this type of
coverage in GCC
and some Rumblings on thinking before
typing
so start with the mcdc so why do we care
about coverage what is it why is mcdc
different from the branch cupboard which
you made on and be familiar with and
what does Mass have to do with all of it
right
so one reason to care if you're in one
of the industries in particular I
mentioned is the lizard people which I
would like to call the regulatory bodies
so if you develop software for planes or
cars or anything that moves or may or
may not kill people
by accident or you know on purpose
um
you might have to obey to these
regulations and uh so do is I don't know
what it is but it's from for the
Aerospace it's the FAA I think that
ratified it for their safety critical
like level a software they mandate that
100 of your code has to pass this
Criterion
for the highest safety levels in cars
and that's typically those that
um deal with the functions I mean you
don't care if your music player stops
but you don't care if your brakes stop
working right they also have to be
tested to the same criteria
uh but I think even then it's it's
underused in the General Industry uh as
a sort of specific probe we're going to
very briefly cover the problem with
brand coverage and I picked a way too
light color for the highlighted rows
um
is that in order to satify Branch
coverage you need two tasks and the
problem is here that you have way more
than two inputs to this decision right
uh like notably you never actually test
if a can be true
and then you go like oh I mean it's a
billion so obviously it can be true but
it may not may not be true if that's the
case or if you have broken parsing
because you're dealing with IO right so
so it can be deeper than that
formally modified condition decision
coverage is satisfied if every entry and
exit Point has been invoked every basic
condition has taken all possible
outcomes and each of the basic
conditions have been showed
independently affect the outcome of the
decision
uh so the first point every entry annexy
point has been invoked this is Branch
coverage right so we can do is I mean
this is Branch coverage everyone like
have you been in the uh then have you
been in the Alps
condition coverages have you pass true
and false to each one of the variables
you put in
um the independence Criterion is what
makes it different and it's a little bit
hard to see but there are different rows
highlighted for every table
and it's this Independence Criterion
that makes it strong and actually that
makes it interesting
so of course what you can do is you can
test the power set of inputs but the
thing is it wouldn't actually give you
more information about the behavior of
your inputs or of your program
uh the motivation it requires M plus one
test cases rather than two to the power
of n and what happens sometimes is I I
write in a paper from NASA from early
90s
that they'd found some cases in the wild
uh in avionics where there were 36
conditionals in an F and who does that
right but sometimes you have to because
of rules like uh like Robert touched on
the asinine
and interestingly uh you can catch some
pieces of bad logic with mcpc
of course the problem is it only tests
the implementation not the spec so if
you're Pro like if you're spec or your
your algorithm is buggy doesn't matter
if your implementation is correct
because it's still the wrong program
it's possible to cheat it with
restructuring we won't have time for
that now but we'll do that in the other
one
and if you look as a whole program
analysis it you're gonna have to in like
in order to actually achieve full
coverage you need a lot of test cases in
not very interesting pieces of your code
base
also it's awful to do without tooling
this is absolutely awful
so I've wrote a patch for that
for GCC
um which uh the the work has been paid
for by involving planet where I'm
employed
uh in total italics up to about 3000
lines
approximately half of that are tests
some is documentation is a little bit of
i o
uh the interesting changes are in the
tree profile file which have 978
editions and about
a third of that are comments like this
high level descriptions
so I think that the total ends up to be
somewhere between M4 and 600 lines to
implement this
which is actually pretty dense largely
because GCC has some good internal
interfaces but also because the program
is short so this is what it looks like
when you do it right
so you compile it with profile
conditioners you run it with your inputs
and then you run g-cover on it
and then it will tell you
what conditions are covered and what
conditions are not covered under this
Criterion
so the question is you obviously run
this with a is true in the third demo
line right
uh why isn't it covered any any good
instincts
yes
yes exactly it's because B is false
which is kind of unintuitive right
because I mean you have it in the input
but it still doesn't get counted why not
because of this Criterion here it has to
independently affect the decision
and it turns out what we're witnessing
here is something called
uh masking
so if you look at this table and again
it's almost impossible to see the blue
but it's line one and line five
they've been highlighted
and you can see in the in the a column
in the first case AES false and the
other case
a is true
but the outcome the decision is still
false in both cases obviously changing
the value away didn't matter at all it
didn't change the outcome so it's not
independently affecting the outcome of
that case
it's called masking and it happens on
the right hand side
of conditions
so in the next talk we're going to go
through a lot of this
but very quickly the observation is that
if you reverse the expression those
masks become short-circuiting
obviously because Boolean expressions
commute
then you can reverse it without actually
changing what values it will accept or
not assuming you have no side effects of
course
so this is going to go through later
today
so let's talk about writing beautiful
programs
because what I realized when I did
is I started solving for the the
simplest of cases like literally my
first test case was if a
right which is already covered by Branch
coverage
because there's this general idea that
if you if you're targeting a general
solution it has to always also solve the
special cases and The Simple Solutions
so you can start by doing those and
drawing some insides
and eventually you add another test case
and you you this is all a classic tdd
then you write the stupidest
implementation possible because you know
you're gonna have to change it
that would solve this this problem
um
and then you walk back whenever you get
a failing test case and you start
understanding why and now it's not about
twiddling you know that array access or
you know inverting accounts you need to
actually understand what why doesn't
this work from a sort of higher level
and what happened was that the more I
started to to try this out the more
confident I became is that both the
approach is viable and was correct
because it started being based on set
theory and a little bit of graph Theory
very like entry level but you know and
it turns out set theory works right
and the program kind of wrote itself
because once you had that description of
how things interacted with each other
problem the program just falls out
so credit where it's due
um
the the title and the idea for the talk
I uh next from Ross Cox right
who has this great post from sometime I
think in the 90s which is called regular
expression matching can be simple and
Fast And the tagline is but it's low in
Python for all Java you know I list a
bunch of languages
and in that he uses uh he discuss a
theory called like he uses automaton
Theory to implement regular expressions
and it becomes a very nice program
reasonably short
quite easy to understand
how it behaves the way it does and he
does it in very plain C right
and for the GCC patch this has been a
bunch of mostly simple relationships
that I've just stacked on top of each
other right so we're going to go through
those
so let's start with the control flow
graph I would say that there there was
publish an algorithm in 2000
9 or 13 I can't remember I think it's
13.
um that describes figuring out condition
coverage from abstract syntax trees
my algorithm does it on control programs
uh so it's it's a little bit different
so the program on the left here is it's
but it
simple
uh well in a a part of as a compiler
transformation will be translated to
something that is pretty similar to the
code on the right you know you have your
label a and then there's a series of
single condition go go-to's right single
position tests with a go to
and this is what the compiler very
quickly sees so when it does a lot of
its optimizations it happens and I want
to intermediate representation that
looks pretty much like that
in GCC it's called gimple and RTL and
maybe one more uh llvm obviously uses
llm ir and they're experimenting with
another one for C plus plus I think
and if you draw it as a graph this is
what it looks like right
formerly the control flow graph is a
directed graph where nodes represent
uninterruptible sequence of instructions
if you have a bunch of arithmetic
they're going to be in the same node
right there's no control flow in
arithmetic
um edges are the next possible Paths of
the execution
and they are labeled fall through truth
or false or conditional when you group
them complex there are a few more that
are used for different kinds but they're
not really relevant for this
and the final property is very important
is that falter and conditional are
mutually exclusive fall through just
means continue to the next node there's
no decision to make
uh whereas conditional obviously you can
go either way right
so the first thing we need to do when
press enter with the control flow graph
is we need to infer the decisions we
need to figure out what exactly are the
Boolean Expressions now
unlike the AST approach you don't
actually have the concept of a Boolean
expression or even the concept of an
expression anymore you have the flow of
the program
so this is what we want this is the goal
I have for the case just for
illustrative purposes added the entry
node that you will find in all control
for graphs but I've omitted it from the
rest of the slides because it's not
really relevant you can just assume it's
there or the previous section of the
program or you know the previous
something
is that but what we want are there three
now is a b and c right because from the
source code it's obvious that that's the
expression and if you ask the AST then
the AST will know that this is the
expression right
from here on it gets a little bit heavy
on the notation please interrupt if
something is very alien I'll try and
make it as understandable as possible
but we need it to the end of it dance
now what this says is one so this is the
first
after I started doing the maths on this
this is one of the first thing I
realized and it turned out after a
little bit more work but this is
probably the key observation that makes
this algorithm work
and like when when you say it out loud
it sounds so obvious right and it pretty
much says that for all of the nodes that
make up a Boolean expression the B is
one Boolean expression right
then
the edges or the successors of that
will have to be in what's called a
closed neighborhood of B
now the neighborhood of a node or a
subgraph are all the nodes that are able
to reach from that graph right so it's a
common thing in computer science
and I mean the neighborhood is
in otherwise defined as
the the Boolean expression itself to
know that make up the Boolean expression
and the outcome of the expression so the
the start of the then and else blocks
right
and what what I really says is that
within a Boolean expression you can only
evaluate or keep on evaluating the
Boolean expression you can't really
Branch off to any or else right
so if you look at that in source it
means that you
the the when you start evaluating the
pair you have to continue to either you
end up in one of the outcomes or to the
end of C there are no other words there
aren't you can't go anywhere else
this is not true in general especially
in C plus plus because you have
exceptions but exceptions don't
contribute to control flow coverage
because you wouldn't complete like you
wouldn't finish evaluating the
expression and so they're ignored
leaving us with a much simpler graph
we're simply ignoring them
but other than that like they can be
considered interruptible now that's what
this Greek thing means right
this is the same proposition slightly
restated in in the context of edges
and it says that all of the edges that
originate from one of the nodes
in a Boolean expression
will go to either another node in the
same expression or one of the two
outcome nodes
and it's a really long way of saying you
have two outcomes of a Boolean
expression right
turns out this is actually a very key
Insight so in this
uh drawing on the right you have the
outcome marked in Gray and the nodes of
the expression marked in blue right
another property of that is that all of
the edges
within a Boolean will be conditional
right
again that's not completely true because
you can have function calls as a that
will then evaluate one of the booleans
but that will just be a long chain of
single fold through edges that we can be
contracted so you can simplify that to
you know being one long conditional Edge
right so again the maths work out
and then the final Insight from this
is that if you look at the last term in
a conditional expression
it has to decide the outcome so you have
short circuiting and the outcome can be
decided by pretty much any of the notes
right or any of the terms in an
expression
but if it's not decided by c c will make
a decision for you right it sounds so
obvious it is so obvious
and what that means is that the
successors of the last term in an
expression in the graph will always be
to the two outcomes
whereas the short circuiting edges will
be to either of the outcomes right
put another way it means that you can't
have a go to that will end up in the
middle of an expression right you can't
put a go to in or a label in front of B
and go to it right it doesn't work
because the expression is an atomic unit
right
okay
so that gave me the first draft you know
for the first phase and it's it's it's a
BFS right
so you do a breadth first or death first
search kind of doesn't matter
so we're gonna do that now
um this is the ground
um do you start with a
and you say okay
there's a condition Edge
um so we get B
what we want to do is we want to gather
all the nodes that we can reach by
following only condition edges right
okay we can reach C condition Edge
we can reach t with the condition Edge
we can reach C but we already have
collected C so we ignore it we've
already collected T to ignore that we
can reach f
um
and that's really it right because you
see
um both false and true have a single
edge which means that they're not
conditional they're fall through right
so we stop searching
this is what it looks like uh with the
cases that you need to check in order to
handle the complex control program thing
in GCC
make a queue and while there is
something in the queue
uh from your starting node
check through its accessor right
if you've already seen it throw it away
if this is you skip it
if it's a back Edge so a typical Loop
edges right or at the end of the loop
you will have a back Edge to the top of
the loop ignore those they they don't
matter
uh there's a dominated relationship
which uh we're not going to go into now
because it doesn't really affect
anything at this point
um and attitude I mean this is a BFFs
right
okay
so we have a slightly different program
where the C is not an or in the in the
if but it's it's in the outcome block of
the then
where is a single conditional and the
control for graph for that is on the
right
so this is one of the I think this is
the fifth test I wrote for this
so we do the same algorithm okay from
here we can conditionally reach R and B
we add those
um
I'm going to try and add c and e but
oops C is not a part of the expression
right so it turns out the simple BF fans
is not sufficient because I mean the
program on the left area is a pretty
common program right and not handling
that is not an option
because we shouldn't include C in the
set we want it to just be a and b right
so I took a step back
and I realized that what the BFS gave me
was a cut okay so a cut is a graph
partitioning
um where you can you can almost imagine
a line that goes through the
the
past the red nodes or edges going into
the red nodes
um
that is immediately reachable with this
BFS and then those adjacent to that
because we're in this neighborhood thing
remember the identity from before
and then we have an observation turned
out to be very useful
and is that for all the edges in
the cut or in in the whatever we find by
reach right so the the
reachable monster conditionals they will
all be conditionals and what that means
is that our outcome
will be a part of what we can reach
right because there has to be
conditional edges into the outcomes
this is a just a very precise way of
saying that
what I also implies is that the graph
we're searching for the expression we're
searching for has to be a part of what
Rich can find right it might find more
so what we now need to use essentially
filter this
and then you notice that there's not
really a path from the done block to the
else block and there is a teeny tiny
Edge case with the go-to with nothing
then I think actually is a
control photograph construction plugin
GCC
that will maybe violate this but for the
most part
you're still interruptible within the
single Boolean expression and it always
has two outcomes and there's no real
communication in between right
and if you formalize that
um
you will see that what what these have
in common if you would if you take this
picture and you would reverse the edges
you'll see that the only way to get into
c and e for the most part when starting
it or actually when starting at a the
only way to get into then and else is to
evaluate all of the Expressions right
and both blocks have the leading or the
conditional expression in common
now formally it means that the ancestors
to the then
uh like for all of the nodes in the then
the Boolean expression will be a part of
its ancestor side so if you if you take
any node in
like uh in in the outcome like in p and
you walk it all the way up to the top of
the graph
B will be a part of that because I mean
in order you're able to reach the then
block
from the Boolean expression right that's
why we have it
and this is pretty cool because they
both have this property right both of
them and the else
in a way you could flip the arrows here
and it would be just as an alien right
it's okay let's let's look at that let's
look at the ancestors
from here
well it's CBN a right you you you can
like any path that will go into queue
might go through or even have to in this
case a b and c
and some applies to P right which makes
sense because they're both the outcome
of C
but r
has a and b
assets its ancestors
and what turns out
is that this is a very good way of of
figuring out
what these have in common uh like if you
look at the neighborhood which is the
first thing you get that isn't a
conditional right
if if you take all of those ancestors
and see what minimal set of ancestors do
they have in common which is what the b
equals
find their big cap
says
that will give you the Boolean
expression because that's the only thing
they both will have in common right
there's a problem with that because our
BFS needs to start at the topmost node
right it has to include all the
expression which means it has to start
to start from the top
and the solution design is actually
remarkably simple is that you can just
Traverse the order or Traverse the graph
in depth first order
so if if V is just if a node you're
evaluating is just a fall through node
mark it skip it throw it out
if it's a conditional node it's the
first conditional node you're getting to
so it has to be the leading term right
[Music]
um
so you do this scan this reach and then
filter
and then you mark it right and so all of
these have now been processed
and if it's already marked in this DFS
search it means that it was already
processed by an earlier leading nodes
it's an internal node in a Boolean
expression and you go through right
so I was thinking about this for a while
again this lead to problems and it may
be may lead to Expressions being
processed out of order which means that
if you have a long program it might uh
you know it might process deep inside
like either inside the block
in the else before the then so it might
not be completely in the order of your
program from top to down because it
depends on how the the order of the
edges in the control flow graph
representation but it doesn't matter
because each of those are independent
anyway
so you know that the expression the
isolated Boolean expression themselves
will be processed in the right order
and then you don't care about the
program being processed in in arbitrary
order
if you put that together you get this
and this is pretty easy to translate to
Super
dialect that GCC usage right
it's it's not a very complicated program
it's too Loops right
and this is defined decision this is
where you start by doing a BFS if it's
just one node in the BFS then it's fine
it's just it's a single single F so you
just throw it out or you just return it
but if not you have to do this thing
where you collect all of the ancestors
of each of the nodes in this
neighborhood which are the deepest
possible candidates
right
and then you take the intersection
this is that function as it's
implemented in GCC minus the setup and
actually minus the setup the tear down
is there
so what's that
15 lines maybe 20 something like that
and this is it kind of materialized
right
and what's nice about that is that
all of these operations are pretty high
level and they map one to one to the
relationship between the graph and the
outcome right
so you have the ancestors of function it
does it collects the ancestors and then
you do
uh bitmaps or sets that's really it
any questions
it's new style so my apologies
I don't like big news time
okay putting that together with the
whole program analysis you you get this
you just do this in DFS order and then
collect each of them so now what you
have when you run this program this too
is pretty easy to translate to C plus
plus when you have this
it's like or rather when you have this
typed up this way the the implementation
just falls out it's remarkable
okay so let's talk about masking and I
would did not actually expect anyone to
get it right that wasn't from the one of
the three aforementioned Industries
but
masking happens
when it turns out the left hand side
doesn't matter because it doesn't change
the decision
because I mean and that happens on the
when the right hand side of an R is true
and the left right hand side of side of
an and is false right and then false
it'll always be false
so the first observation I made there is
or pretty early on is that Boolean
expressions are isomorphic under the
operator
so
these are the two expressions under
respective control flow graphs and when
I if you just invert the labels
you get the same graph
which is pretty neat
so I wondered why and and this is where
the Theory comes in right because I mean
it's fine that they have this property
or it's they seem to have this property
but why understanding why means you can
leverage it and the previous really just
say the Morgan and then go out of there
and get out
um that they have to be
the implication of that is that we
actually don't need to understand the
operator unlike in the AST approach that
was discussed by the University of
Minnesota while I'm
friends
you only need to understand the shape
so if you look at what masking happens
from a control photograph perspective
it's
so very briefly masking happens
um or rather a a condition is
independent
if you can give the same input vector
change it change that one variable and
while keeping all of the other elements
in the vector effects like the function
inputs fixed
and have the decision be different right
and it turns out in in graphs
this uh happens when taking another path
still ends up with the same node right
so when you have a branch you can either
go to the true to the false if you go to
the false but you keep on making the
choices you otherwise would have made
and you end up in the same note so I
have an example of that here
in for a or b right on the right hand
the the right one you can see it goes
through b but still ends up in true
right because B was said to be true
in the middle one B was had to be true
but it was never evaluated because
you're a short circuit
and this is actually a key insight
because masking can only happen at nodes
that has multiple predecessors right
and if you have multiple predecessors
that means that you are the destination
of someone else's Short Circuit
an implication of that is that we know
where to start looking for masking
effects
right
because remember when you're looking at
this from a competitive perspective
you're giving an arbitrary graph you
don't really know how you got there all
you can do is maybe recognize the shape
it's a little bit of repetition from I
guess sixth form
uh it's the association right
um under the same Boolean operator you
can remove the params it doesn't matter
it doesn't change anything
this actually turns out to be very
useful
because that means that you can take any
Boolean expression and rewrite it into
an alternate or canonical one I actually
don't have a good name for it forum
where you have a chain of Opera operands
with no parents
and you have the parents every time the
operator changes so you kind of get this
nesting effect right
and it turns out that if you look at the
control flow graph that will be
represented pretty much exactly like
that that's that's how the control flow
graph gets constructed because of this
relationship
and masking will propagate until the
operator changes right so in this case
if you have D equals true
then it doesn't matter what B and C are
because the forensic expression the sub
expression will always be true right
but a like an and expression will never
be masked by its right hand sign being
true right so a is not mass but B and CR
because there's an operator change right
however the outcome of a sub-expression
as a whole may still mask
outside of this again this is not very
it if you just look at the proposition
it's very intuitive right because you
can do substitution so if we would
substitute b or c for f
and then write it as a and F
I mean it's obvious that F can
can mask right
so if C in this case would be evaluated
to force that actually also implies that
b is false because otherwise C would be
short-circuited and we wouldn't have
this problem in the first place but it
would then also mask a
however c will not mask B because you
have to have a false B in order to get
there in the first place and you never
must from the left hand side
so this kind of follows from from the
observation from before is that uh s
Omega means the last term in s right
s is now a sub expression whereas V was
the full Boolean expression now the last
term in a sub expression can short
circuit in the super expression
that kind of follows from the same thing
with the the the last term in an
expression
will have to decide the expression right
because there are no more terms to the
rights of it
so I came up with this funky way of
drawing it where you actually draw it in
nesting levels right
so
uh on top you will see it Ronin is
alternating form
and the lower figure is where you're
drawing this
uh with as the operator alternates so in
but you can imagine in between all of
the
the terms in the top row there will be
and and there will be ores in between
the second row and then ants again in
the third row and it will go
and it will alternate
and when you put it out on a paper like
this you actually get some interesting
things you can do with arrows
so if you if you make C through or H
true you will see how short circulating
works right because you basically move
one level up and go to the next one on
the right
and it doesn't matter what level you're
at because remember that this
propagation is firewalled by the change
of the operator
when D is true
in this case
it will keep on evaluating e because the
sub expression C or D is evaluated to
true and true does not short circuit or
uh sorry and right it keeps on
evaluating
but if it is false it short circuits all
the way here
but if these phones they will also do
one more thing
right
because it will mask A and B
and there you have this interesting
effect that when you see a lower level
short circuit it's super expression then
there will also be a masking effect
because you're now with the wrong value
at the right operator if you will right
turns out this observation is very
useful
so
when you're evaluating a condition you
have two possible outcomes like either
you Short Circuit the right operands or
you keep on evaluating right this it
sounds silly to have to to repeat it but
it's actually very useful
and the implication here
is that if one of the edges is short
circuiting
the other one has to be a masking Edge
right
because this relationship is so intimate
and now we can finally State our problem
right so given a path of incoming edges
which one is masking and which one is
short circuiting how can you tell
and the implications we kind of need of
or rather what we would get from being
able to answer that as an ordering
where if you have two nodes then one is
less than the other if it's a left off
Rand right because we it has to go that
way
um and it's writer if it's the right
operand within the same expression
and add in
how to figure that out
the resolution is topological sort
which is really just a DFS like you do a
depth first search and you record them
as you go
so now we have that right
this relationship will get the the
this is like the implication is pretty
much the the definition of the
topological sort right
and writing a topological story is easy
because you go to Wikipedia and you
search top sort and you copy it from
there
okay
so now
given a pair of notes
which happen to be the predecessors
of the third node right
then you will be able to compare them
and order them right
then you will have that the lower one of
those
will have to be some sub-expressions
final term or last term
as an implicational bias that you now
also know the outcomes of that
expression
and just further notation s is one of
the sub-expressions of of B so just go
back here then s could be G or H or an i
or J or something right any of these
most of those are single term but you
have a couple of multi-term ones
and the other implication is that the
other one then taking the M taking the
Higher One the deeper one in the graph
uh when you take that one that uh
the the nodes in s will be masked right
it's a bit of repetition
inside the closed neighborhood
of the
is just you know pick all of the
successors
of the nodes in B this is assuming in OB
then you get the uh the close
neighborhood
and the open neighborhood is it's the
outcome
so anything that was true for B the full
Boolean expression will obviously be
true for a sub-expression which is still
a valid Boolean expression in its own
right you know
and now we can Define the final problem
which is to figure out given this Edge
I'm taking
what nodes will be masked what terms
will be masked
there is one intermediate problem in
that is that you might have more
incoming edges and this is always if you
have a bazillion terms you will have a
lot of short circuiting and if you're a
lot of short circuiting you have a lot
of masking effects
because you can't have one without the
other
which again is shown by reversing the
expression right
and the solution to that is really to do
a Cartesian product and filter
because we can order we can compare in
constant time
it's very easy to just I mean sort them
right and process them
so let's do that for this A and B and C
program
this is one pair of short circuits on
masking Edge and you if you apply the
masking thing so if you take
C to false obviously a didn't matter
right because a is on the left hand
there are all ants between right
and the same thing applies to B if if
you take
The Edge C to F then it didn't matter
that B to C was true
but also
um
if you take B is false then it didn't
matter what a was
and otherwise all that put together I
first see you can just combine these two
right
this is the same Expressions before but
I've substituted the B for an S because
now we're on the on the sub expression
so this relationship has a surprisingly
useful implication
and that is that if you define the first
um
I don't know start S I don't know the
first s s0 to be the outcome which you
now have because you have the last term
and the outcome right
you have the successor function
then
you can
and really when you think about this is
the same problem we did when we found
the expressions in the first and
isolated the decisions in the first
place but in Reverse now we have the
outcomes and we need to figure out what
terms are a part of this sub-expression
right
but now we know what the outcomes are we
didn't know anything about it other than
the leading term when we went it from
above right
um
so then if you look at what nodes
have both of their successors in the set
of nodes I've already seen or collected
and if you start with the outcome
because of this property that all of the
nodes in an expression will have its
edges either to some other node in the
expression or one of the outcomes
you eventually get a fixed point
by repeatedly seeing you know what nodes
have all of their
successors in the large the growing s
where there are no more notes to add
right so this is a very
you know notation heavy weight off
denoting something is actually pretty
easy to do by hand so we can have this
Expression A and B and C or D
and this is our short circuiting Target
the short circuit is C2
D so D is short-circuited
then we have the CTS as a short
circuiting Edge and D to T is our
masking Edge so taking the edge B to T
wood mask BNC and here you can tell
immediately you know from being human
where you want to end up you want to end
up with b and c right
so let's do it
we know that the last term in the
expression we're looking for
is C
right
because it's the lower ranked of the two
nodes
in the topological sort
and we know that the outcome
are are the successives of this node
which are DNT
right so this is the outcome we start by
marking
which means that our initial zero
is D and T and now I'm Mark the edges
gray to our those ideas that go into our
s n
and you can see C now is is an offline
no sorry
it's not an option it's it has no
children anyway what's the term for that
anyone else
pardon Leaf thank you it's a leaf so
that's really what you're doing you know
you pick the leaf you remove the edge
obviously it's almost like doing it from
a tree and then you look for new leaves
so that's what we're doing
so S1 as you know you add the C and then
you remove the edge C to B you need the
same thing for B but a still has an
outgoing Edge right so uh that's our
limit
this is our fixed point you can do this
however many times you want and you will
never get a larger set than S2 which is
DTC and B
and then we remove our initial two
outcomes because obviously they aren't a
part of the sub-expression they're the
outcomes
what we're left with are B and C turns
out this works for any graph
if you put it together in sort of
algorithmic notation
if that's the thing it looks something
like this
where the first two lines are pretty
much specifying what and how to interact
right but I think it's much easier to
look at it in terms of you know remove
the edges from the graph
uh when there or remove the leaves and
then obviously the edges that would go
through that leaf and then keep on
removing until you're at the fixed
points
this too is pretty easy to just straight
up map to C plus I would do the
Cartesian product is
a nested for Loop over the predecessors
where you do the if smaller or larger
than continue right
the program just fell out
so I look at some consequences and
drawbacks of the algorithm and of the
approach so the good is that if you
implement this in the middle and it's
useful for more languages
so it's largely been tested with c and
some C plus plus because C plus plus
have fun things like exceptions and
primarily exceptions but also classes
that can sometimes obscure things
I tested it for d uh and D has checked
array access like bounce tracks which
means that every array access now gets a
conditional check which is nice
or not defending
uh which it does pick up on and it's
consistent with highgco operates for
this Branch coverage
the ban is that it's very sensitive to
control for graphic construction and
that also means that currently it is
useless in go because go uses a
different strategy for constructing the
control flow graph where it constantly
calls booleans
I have an idea of viewing doing data
flow analysis on top of that to undo the
work that the go frontenders and also to
uh to stop some programmers from
cheating coverage doing that which would
be pretty cool it would be an even
stricter form of mcdc
uh and again the bad is that it does
pick up on an implicit conditionals
because may or may not want to to
have bounce check of every array access
in your test Suite
and some experiences are
indistinguishable because they're
controllable control flow graphs are the
same that may or may not be a feature
you can expect your compiler to do some
term rewriting for you so maybe that's
cool
thank you
and then there's the Beautiful
so I'm actually very happy with this
program I the the first first draft
which was before I started trying to do
the maths on this was absolutely
terrible
awful
uh and really didn't work it was way too
complicated and it handled most of the
special cases until I added one tiny one
that broke the entire model right
because it turned out the algorithm was
wrong
because I didn't actually understand the
relationship in the graphs
programs then has this natural way of
becoming way much like higher level so
most of the operations in the actual
algorithm itself in the code in civil
Plus
or like they're various sets operations
and graph
traversals and searches right they're
easy to understand and then you can
combine these higher level operations
which are now simple function calls
rather than having to master or you know
what through hundreds of lines of Loops
in special cases and checks that don't
really make sense to anyone unless
you're deeply familiar with how it works
it turns uh too that this is a pretty
good opportunity for good naming because
now you actually have an intent that
you're able to put into the name and it
makes code almost more malleable because
now you can do some implementation
changes but you also know that you need
to say
um
Implement whatever variants that sets
operations would do so you can do
something other than a bit mask
that would map back to some node array
you can do literally this with standard
set if you'd like to but you still have
to obey the rules of the set not of some
maybe obscure implementation detail it
also leaves a lot of room for cool
optimizations that you can do because
they they optimization that are possible
because of these set relationships
rather than
uh maybe a cool trick that happened to
work because of representation
and honestly it's pretty fast to
complete programs notice I didn't say
right programs but Complete because I
think if you consider writing plus the
debugging and testing you have to do
when you don't have a strong theoretical
theoretical foundation for what you're
doing
it's faster to type but I think they're
slower to complete
we do have a few minutes I would like to
also mention how it's instrumented but
to be fair this approach isn't mine this
I installed from the University of
Minnesota and there are violin and his
guys
better observation is that
instrumentation has to be fast right
in particular because those that care
the most for mcdc
tend to also Target embedded which means
that there are limitations to how
intrusive instrumentation can be
and the good thing is that you really
only need a handful of bitwise
instructions in order to make this work
so remember that there is an ordering
like you can sort the nodes because of
this topological sort
which also means that we can sort B
right so if you have a Boolean
expression you have a bunch of nodes
that you know belong to the same Boolean
expression
then you can sort them right
and that also means that there is a
bijection from the natural numbers to
the nodes in b
so what we're doing is that we
initialize two Global accumulators for
every decision and roughly speaking
that's an if but you get them in the
Wilds you get them in the do Wireless in
the fort like anything that would change
control flow
you get two Global accumulators you can
fold these if you want to save even more
on space into one and then use a
protocol for which bit means one
so here they're represented by a 4-bit
integer
uh in GCC they typically use 64-bit for
Intel
it's a variable with the type so it
depends on your target architecture
um and then there's an expression on the
right A and B or C okay
and since there is a simple injection we
can do this
there's not a the first term is the
least significant that b is the second
month you know blah blah
so if you then run it
with zero zero one
you now see what bits you set right
so this is how the global accumulators
work and these are stored and
persistently in between functions and
eventually this is what gets written to
the G color
file
so you run it again for zero zero zero
and now you've set
um a for false
and then for
uh
a and not b or c
then you set the
SE two
the local accumulators pretty much
behave in the same way but remember that
we have the masking thing oh yeah oh so
by the way so since these are integers
updating these masses is a simple bit
a bit twice or right
for the local accumulators we need to do
a little bit more
so what we do is that whenever you take
and this is what happens in the function
so you have
because
a function is pretty much single
threaded all the way down conceptually
it is sufficient to have
two accumulators one for three and one
for false for all of the conditions in a
function so here we do save some space
[Music]
um
so then what we need to do
is that whenever we we take an edge in
the control flow graph as we evaluate
one value to true or false
uh we record that index
of the edge that corresponds to it right
and then we look into this masking
Vector this table of masks and then we
see will this trigger masking operation
and we just remove the things that had
previously been set
that would have been that are not masked
away
so in in this case e is The Edge taken
and M of the
are the notes that will be masked when
taking marriage
this is what it would look like in the
binary for the function A or B I picked
up
two term one to just keep the example
smaller
so you would have a Prelude which would
reset your accumulators
the local accumulators
and then you just run the program right
so you see if you take the edge a if a
is true then you update the true array
with one
right
and then otherwise you update the false
array for a with one
and then you either go to the true or to
the B depending on the value right
and B has a masking effect so it's B if
B is true then you need to remove the
value
that would have been set
um
by a
so that's where you do
the and
before finally updating it with
yourself
and of course at the end of the Boolean
expression
uh these are flushed
right
to the global ones
in in implementation wise you need to
add the instrumentation code whenever
you're taking an edge to the outcome in
order to satisfy you know exceptions and
it doesn't matter too much but that's
where we insert instrumentation code so
just a handful of bitwise instructions
no branching it's very fast
um yeah that's that's really it any
questions oh yeah I have this one though
so
some graphs will be indistinguishable so
A and B and C and if a b c in order if
there are no alpses
will be the same control flow graph and
therefore have the same coverage report
which is not necessarily what you expect
when you type it because again we've
thrown away the syntax but semantically
this makes sense right semantically
these two are identical
all right
um that's lunch uh if you have any
questions uh or if you want to see how
it works on the computer
uh grab me at lunch or between sessions
or come to the talk in a few hours thank
you very much